[MUSIC PLAYING]
My name is Robert Lepage,
and I'm a stage director.
But I'm also an actor, and
sometimes I'm a film director.
I do a lot of work in the opera.
And so I'm pretty much have
my finger in many, many pies.
But my main thing
is I have a theater
company called Ex Machina.
We're based in Quebec City.
What I thought that
this morning would
be maybe interesting to explain
to you, my method of working.
It's more fun to tell
stories as a group.
And it's more fun and richer
to take everybody's experience
and disciplines and make
them converge together.
You help the piece say what
it is that it wants to say.
So it's not starting
with that idea.
It's letting it appear
and imposing itself.
If you look at the anthropology
of theater, it's about playing.
And that'll bring us
to our resource today.
Ex Machina is working on a new
piece based on playing cards.
The project is
called Playing Cards.
We believe that the content
is in here, that there's
tons of stories in this.
And I believe that if we
give you that resource
that you actually can come up
with your own interpretation.
My mom used to play poker
every night when I was a kid.
So I see cards and I have
flashbacks immediately.
So it's a family thing.
It was a family issue for sure.
Yeah.
When I was talking about
the way we explore this.
And at least one thing we
could try this afternoon
in the playfulness
of this is we try
to play cards, just play cards.
Just do that.
OK, I get it.
[CHATTER]
[LAUGHTER]
Do it, do it, do
it, do it, do it.
Embarrassing.
[INAUDIBLE]
Because I can't defend
anything else but [INAUDIBLE]
[CHATTER]
You can throw it down
at any time and be like,
it's now a hearts or
it's now a diamonds.
And the object is to get
rid of all your cards.
Are there any cards
that have special--
Just eights.
OK.
[CHATTER]
Anyone else want to--
OK, all games are over.
All right.
So the last thing I want
us to take some time to do,
which is something
I always try to do
as part of the
exploration thing,
is that we'll just do one
big collective drawing.
There's no rules to this.
You just draw the
impressions that you
have of what we did together
today about cards, whatever.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We're just going to
quickly go around,
everyone, just to know
what who contributed what.
What about you?
I had at the axe to the
players at the main table.
Oh this axe here.
That's the axe.
OK.
I did the outline of this
purple figure, the train
that people turn into a train.
What's that outline?
So it's as you go left to
right, it's the number of cards
that you need for
the hand in poker.
So it's one card, one pair,
two pair, three of a kind.
It's an interesting pattern.
I added the mustache.
Aha.
We found the culprit.
Sorry.
With experience, we've
learned that we should not
force connections.
We let them.
And eventually two or three
things seems to go together.
And we go, oh, there's
a pattern there.
And then we sit and we
score, which is of course
is a weird way of
thinking because we're
used what we were brought up
to say, you're the master.
You're the writer.
You're the guy who
controls the show, who
says to the show what to do.
We say, no.
It's exactly the opposite.
We trust that the show
will tell us what to do.
It's an obscure process.
I agree.
Any questions?
Any doubts?
Any fears?
So good luck with everything.
And have fun.
That's the most important thing.
Have fun and be playful.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
[INAUDIBLE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]